I was in a psychiatric ward for three
weeks we both dabbled in in some crazy
behavior and ended up in Psychiatric
Centers I do remember it being pretty
scary and there were certain people in
one of the psych wards I was in who were
like just trapped and couldn't get out
like they'd been there for for a long
time how do you not get out because
you're there for a psychiatric
evaluation is what a 5150 is yeah and
you're constantly being evaluated so if
like the the staff of the psychiatric
ward evaluate even deem you unfit to be
released they just keep you
there's some like sadistic people and
people smearing all over the wall
some people that work there too there's
some sadistic yeah like the power thing
yeah the power thing